you guys didn't win but also you did
sorta win in life maybe better than the
Mirrorball huh it's a consolation prize
I guess I think love is better than a
mirror ball honestly this whole
experience I mean I told her so many
times I don't care if you win the
Mirrorball cuz we're out here doing
something that we love and it's so much
fun and to do with Alexis has been
incredible so I'm just so thankful for
this whole journey what will you miss
most about this and about each other the
worst blank slate all over again
bolsters back on it was the most
stressful day especially because we came
on from such a high from Monday we're
saying okay let's do the next dance but
it was so much fun and I feel like
that's why Monday's were so special
every Monday we came out here and it was
the time of my life
and I do this every day but just to be
able to go out here and have such a good
time it really made life amazing how
will you guys spend time together
outside of dancing now no we can be
normal I don't have the I don't have the
feature five hours a day everyday so we
can just go hang out what do date night
look like and what does this romance
look like outside of the ballroom scene
guys keep saying that we're really
excited because now we can just go hang
out
how serious is this I mean you drop the
l-bomb in tonight's package yeah you
said and I quote I really found love
haven't watched those for sure like I
haven't seen packages so that was taken
out of context are you guys spending the
holidays together yes you guys met each
other's family yes sure she met my
parents just because my parents don't
live here so it was amazing to have them
in the audience and what do your parents
think of this one I mean what can you
not think of her she's such a sweet
person and she's so caring and it's
amazing what do you feel like you
learned most about yourself I learned
what I'm capable of like it's weird
because yeah I was scared of failure but
I think mostly I was scared of success
because you don't know what's after that
and that's it's like the fear of the
unknown of like accomplishing that dream
and being like oh my god I did that it's
almost that's almost more scarier than
failing to music what are you most proud
of of her now that we're done with this
season
it's over I'm so proud that she never
gave up I'm a hard future and I yell a
lot but she never gave up which was
really cool like she she earned her spot
here
how are your future partners gonna stack
up against this one she's gonna be a
hard one I mean I've learned so much
when I learn have so much patience so my
next partners are lucky
where the patience he keeps talking
about I haven't seen it not even attend
to more questions you guys finally
kissed I mean you guys kissed in the
package but now live on television there
was a kiss tonight you're special
the whole night felt like awesome
moments you know and it actually went by
so fast I can't wait to go back home and
watch it back just like live through it
again because it was so special what do
you guys make a Bobby in Sharna winning
I am I couldn't be more proud for both
of them I know Sharon has been in the
final so many times and to finally get a
win it's amazing for her but not another
note for Bobby he had no experience he
came out here and just had fun you know
he was scared but he just he overcame it
with the sheer fact of God here and
entertainer I'm not gonna lie I forgot
about his heart upbringing just because
you know he's done such incredible
things this whole season that it was
actually nice to me to think you know
he's worked so hard to be here and he
deserves it
[Music]
you